let's just say high school prepared me
for this hey I'm Hannah I'm here fresh
up another battle with Joe Mackey Joe
how are you feeling well I'm feeling
like I was cannon fodder out there Sam
is a roastmaster master you know they
say winning is not everything but it is
you made him battle I didn't make him I
requested that he battle I thought it
would be good for him he begged me to do
it he need this for his career things
are not going well and I said okay I'm a
good person yeah he's like calling me
and he's like it's it okay if I told
them you have a DD and I'm like Jesus
Christ
I've never roasted a Furby before so you
look like pee-wee Herman if his big
adventure was going to Dunkin Donuts
Sam's joke about pee-wee Herman I used
to get called that a lot in high school
and you know it was cool for a while and
then things kind of went south for him
and hopefully that'll happen to Sam no
no oh I wanted to say up top that he
sounds like every woman that's ever told
me to watch The Handmaid's Tale Rain Man
boobs I was gonna call him that oh he
went to Penn State so I was gonna say
he's the least funny Joe that's ever
gotten to Penn State giving you some
good some good footage here I said I
want to make Sam angry because he turned
to the teen Wolf's brother that is good
great just bombed with the crew here I
feel worse now Tim looks like she just
found out you can eat bananas do you
think it's more on your parents or
personality guys we know what's
important in here the outside and you've
never heard someone me like Kim's a
bitch and I'm like losing sleep over at
night if one person says anything about
a mustache hair of mine I'll kill myself
if someone makes fun of me for having
short hair so I know I have short hair
but one time someone made fun of me for
having a giant warhead and it's been
bothering me for years well if you have
a large forehead I have a large forehead
so this is awesome I just learned a lot
about repertory I'm not even battling
this isn't fair what hurt more being
told you look like Jeff Dunham or Amy
Shue
Olivia has the body of Lena Dunham in
the face of Jeff Dunham Olivia looks
like Amy Schumer if she lets a mean
comments get to her well Amy Schumer is
a lot prettier than Jeff Dunham so I'm
gonna have to go with Jeff Tom when I
went to get a haircut today I wasn't
like give me the Jeff Dunham I want to
look nothing like Amy Schumer is there
one joke you had that you didn't use any
wish you had I thought that she was
gonna say something about me being
Puerto Rican and I was gonna say that
she's a lot like Porto Rico after the
hurricane because the harder you hit her
the wetter she gets Wow Kim that joke
needs more adjusting than your IUD after
a night out in Harlem we hug shake and
it's all I'm so sweaty I wouldn't do
that to okay but is this weird know
what's great that's good they got a huge
laugh I got more than Mack you got all
night
[Music]
[Applause]